Teddy's learning he's the grasshopper
he's learning from the master that's the
way I look at it
[Laughter]
garbage you know when you're a
fashionista like me you can pick style
out five yards away already I'm kicking
Teddy's ass here this is amazing I mean
who knew who knew you could go with a
cheapo like Teddy and get some great
pieces you're not here with that let the
shopping begin who doesn't like shopping
[Music]
hey Mr Wonderful here again with Teddy
and a very exciting time one more and
I'll tell you why we're in the Bucharest
store this is probably the most
beautiful retail outlet in the world for
watches it's an experience it's like
half Museum half retail store but it's
got tons of Brands and I mean tons if
you want to watch this is the place to
come on Earth however Teddy has another
challenge you know let's be honest I
keep kicking his ass in these things
every time you know it's true but he
wants to throw yet another Gauntlet on
the floor another watch on the floor he
has a new idea I really like let's hear
it Teddy anybody could win when you have
an unlimited buddy like Kevin I'm gonna
bring him back down to earth I'm gonna
test you today limited budget twelve
thousand five hundred dollars per watch
no that's the total of your entire
collection I'm gonna put you to the test
last time your collection was twelve
thousand five hundred dollars yes that's
crazy
I don't think you can do it I can look I
can do it there's no question but and
luckily we're in a place where they have
enough timepieces within that range
and I I'll give you some respect on this
thing because two years ago when I got
started on this journey with Teddy
um
these watches he was talking about I was
just saying why do you like poo poo
garbage but I've come to respect because
I'm a dial guy you know it doesn't have
to cost a lot of money for me to fall in
love with a piece it has to have a great
dial it has to be different than all the
other pieces I have and all of a sudden
you started bringing these low end
pieces with spectacular dials and I
started collecting them and buying them
and now these are some of the most
exciting pieces so when I'm walking
around with something that I bought for
eight hundred dollars and someone says
what is that I'm thinking to myself
maybe he's not nuts after all maybe
there's Merit to having a barbell
approach yes high-end I love it but why
not also dabble in the low end for the
dials because you really can get breadth
to your collection when you do this I
agree 100 so that's going to be the
theme of today same type of setup as
last time so you can choose what you
want to do with your money we'll
alternate back and forth yeah and we
can't go over that budget of 12 500 I
want to give you a little bit more this
includes taxes because we are New York
City we're going to exclude taxes so
just to give us a little bit more
flexibility got it okay okay so we look
at the sticker price now we've got to be
sticker sensitive here because I want to
come up with at least three pieces maybe
four we'll see but let's start shopping
first things first we flip the coin last
time I flipped you flipped this time I
will call it I'll call it you'll call it
so this is the two options here just
like an NFL kickoff NFL Sunday you guys
playing this coin flip so the winner has
two options to choose from they can
either go at the store first
or you can then defer until the end then
all the piece will be lined up and you
can do a swap with the other person's
pieces and the last time we did this I
really screwed him on the Swap and
that's how I won that contest hands down
I gave it to him at the beginning
because I didn't have faith in him but
you know hey you did pretty well I was
picking up all the nice pieces and then
Kevin saw what you know was left over
and you know did what he needed to do
but well none of that today let's do the
flip let the contest begin let the
shopping begin who doesn't like shopping
what are you calling I'm going to call
tails
that's Tails yeah baby I'll defer
I don't like how this is already set up
I went with it last time I went with it
last time that's why I'm doing it this
way all right so I go first you do let's
go shopping all right let's go so what
I'm thinking about here is I I like your
strategy of trying to pick out say you
know three to five pieces that's
probably where I'm going to be yeah
these are these are in this section of
this incredible location probably the
best selection of entry-level pieces in
the world everything is covered here
most of the pieces here are talking
about under five thousand dollars from
this corner on this is in the basement
so and if you're looking to buy a watch
for the first time you want to come here
I mean you can't get plus they have the
inventory which is a problem these days
so we're alone jeans here a brand that I
have a lot of respect for given that
I've actually wore one of these pieces
on Shark Tank this year the sector
exactly yeah it was and I I met I met
them through you and I bought that in
Miami I remember we shot the episode
yeah it was a great episode it was great
okay so you got to go from scanning
I do want to do a long jean and there's
actually something that I saw here which
I was at the unveiling of this watch and
now it looks like they're finally
delivering them this is the ultra crime
I'm gonna do this tell me about the
piece so the ultra cron is looking back
to a historic reference from the brand
but why it's special five Hertz movement
so most of their movements around 3.5
Hertz so this is high frequency
something like the Zenith el primero as
an example so probably one of the most
attainable High beat movements you're
going to find I think this is right
around 3 500 I think on the bracelet a
little bit more but I saw that and I
want to do it let's talk about the style
of that watch divey kind of sportsy yes
bracelets a little different it's more
of like a mesh multi-link style bracelet
but it's a little larger for my taste
they're indicating here you can go total
sport right good yep you can put the
NATO on it yeah okay something that's
gonna be my first pick and price point
it's right around 3 500.37. so you're
taking a third of your budget right out
of the gate why not
very risky Teddy what are you gonna do
well listen I'm just pointing out the
weakness in your decision but that's all
right I like the piece I can never win
around here I don't like this if there's
always risk in every decision I'm just
pointing out the risk all right
portfolio management so that is your
long jeans that's give me my pick okay
okay now probably it's only going to do
one watch per brand I'm not going to
double dip and you don't have to do long
jeans well I'm not
I'm not saying I won't however I'm
getting into a new space these days you
should be aware of the smaller size dial
okay and immediately catching my eye
with this whole red vibe that I have all
right is this and I think probably very
attractive Price Right Here Legend diver
Legend diver what is that 36 36 running
the money so I'm thinking Legend diver
36 Red Band already red kind of ruby-ish
dial really fits into what I'm doing
with my whole red thing Red Band on
everything I'd like to try it can we try
it out yeah can we try it yeah I don't
know how that's going to wear on you
it's quite small I know but lately I'm
supporting this smaller diameter I'm all
for it I'm all for it um it can be very
stylish I never used to do it but now
um I am I've brought several pieces that
way what are we thinking actually I
think it looks pretty good
that I think works
you know when you're a fashionista like
me you can pick style of five yards away
now let's talk about price point what
are we talking about here
yeah baby come on
2 400 out of my 12 500 budget and I look
already I'm I'm kicking Teddy's ass here
this is amazing absolutely all right all
right all right that's my choice very
stylish
love it okay all right where are we now
Boris tell us about the brand Teddy so
auris is based in the Swiss German parts
of Switzerland independent brand really
cool use of eclectic materials they were
one of the early adopters of bronze they
recently unveiled new caliber 400s so
that's getting their five-day power
Reserve they have two thousand dollars
is mostly their Salida movements and
then they extend extend up from there
very interesting dial work here I mean
look at this these Blues these pinks
these are sort of Tara kind of uh
thematic which is very hot these days
also that looks like a 36 38 maybe
that's a 38 for the pointer dates yeah
it's a nice watch these are very nice
pieces what's the price point in this so
those are all in the two thousand dollar
range except the one in the top right
that one's going to be higher because
that has the caliber 400 so that's going
to be around in the threes attractive
I was also looking down here at some of
the bronze it's your call though it's
your pick anything in here you're going
to go with you know what
I'm gonna go with the pointer date this
is my favorite collection I liked your
idea of going with the red yeah I'm
gonna do the same thing but I'm gonna
get a bronze case out of it and bracelet
yeah I mean bronze is hot these days I
mean it's just that's very attractive
watch very risky because remember I have
the opportunity to do a Switcheroo on
them at the end he's not gonna do double
red I might I might you don't know but
you know it's it's my option which is
what I love Teddy's in a bad situation
here but he's made a good call on this
all right I'm getting up there all right
so that's half your budget blown already
a little bit less than half okay
um and we don't have to go in order we
don't have to go brand by brand no I
know I know I'm just you know I'm
looking at dials you know I'm a dial Guy
these dials are very interesting very
interesting I'm looking for stuff that I
don't have in my collection already in
terms of dial but and also auris is you
know I have nothing from them in my
collection because to me it was a watch
that you know wasn't collectible
initially but now that you've got me
into these entry level watches I'm
getting such remarkable outcomes people
are asking me all about them
they do a lot of crazy limited editions
or some over here that they've done so
this is the okabongo editions I have the
green texture dial same here with this
New York Harbor Edition and then you
have that looks like a 39 or 40 right
that's a 41 I think it's a larger dial
yeah what about this
that's a diver 65 yeah that is kind of
where they're more traditional 1960s
just minimalist looking dive watch yeah
yeah so that's interesting I'm thinking
maybe I make a move here for the first
time on aorus okay and I go limited
edition and I go green dial 40 mil I
think okay yeah that's what I'm thinking
you want to pull that out let's pull
that out let's have a look at that once
you can take a closer look at this dial
this is a pretty special dial too so
there's there's a lot of texture in that
dial
so this was for a they do a lot of uh
like altruistic causes and connections
so this is for like a doctor's
organization that do a lot of like
relief work in Africa yeah and this dial
is made to resemble like the grassy
planes as you're in helicopter they do a
lot of this like relief so that's the
whole point of that dial what they're
trying to emulate there Well you
certainly know the story on this piece
it's it's very different and that's what
I like about it and it will work with a
red band which is always my
consideration can I put the watch can I
put the piece on television so you know
you can see that it's going to work
Christmas party right now right yeah
it's okay it's okay so that's two okay
fair fair let's move on let's move on
now I have dived into Hamilton
Hamilton's a sweet brand yeah it's a
great and it's one of my go-to pieces
when I'm traveling because it looks good
it was brass if you recall what I bought
I don't even see it here anymore yeah
the bronze is gone yeah I think this is
a good opportunity to get my chronograph
I'm going to do the green dial
intramatic Chrono wow I like that what's
the price on that that's just over two
thousand dollars I mean like 21 I mean
he chose wisely and I may just take it
from him at the end we'll see I like
that pastel looking green yeah it works
with that leather band it would also
work with a red band so he's already
setting things up no no no you're not
taking that all right so you you have
three right I have three okay and you're
still under twelve thousand so under
twelve thousand I think I have some room
to grow too let's just quickly gaze over
here Neato is a brand and they don't
have the craziest selection here no but
in terms of what they do for the dollar
amount I handle their pieces and I'm
like just I'm always impressed they have
their Ocean Star collection which is
more their dive watches their
multi-forward is more just kind of every
day and then they have things like this
it's a bar and Shelly watch all of these
classic dress I mean you know that is
such a classic look what's the price
point on this stuff talking about a
thousand bucks for that one very good
it's very good so it's very well done
these are mechanical movements
mechanical movements they're owned by
the swash group as well so they're kind
of I used to think that was an negative
but after I've seen what they did with
Omega I'm very impressed with Swatch
being able to differentiate these Brands
and maintain price point think about all
the luxury groups every luxury group is
specifically only catering to the luxury
segment when you think about Swatch they
have everything from Swatch all the way
up to Brigade yeah it's diversification
and I I agree with that philosophy too
as a collector I think everything should
be represented so I may be only getting
one more piece so I've got to be careful
that's interesting I
yes but what about rattle
Serrano is very well known in countries
like Pakistan some other places in the
Middle East things like the diastar
crazy looking watch that's what they're
known for but also what they're known
for is their use of ceramic so they do
some of the most attainable ceramic made
watches and bracelet watches that you
can find out there on the market so not
as caught on in the US the bezel is
ceramic on this piece bezel ceramic and
then they also have you know this is a
woman's piece but you can see that is
fully ceramic case and everything this
very much reminds me of a Tudor look
even with the the dial itself you want
to know something personal I own that
watch exactly really I do
well then what's the price point on that
it's just over two thousand dollars I'm
taking it that's it that's my third
piece right there now he's jogging my
style and everything look at this no no
please can we open that up yeah still
checking on my wrist this is this is a
really interesting shopping spree I'm
getting some great are you kind of
surprised with how much I am surprised
very classic look beautiful dial I mean
look at that you can see it from across
the room it's sporty it's divy but it's
also elegant at an incredible price two
thousand dollars and it's thin I mean I
don't know if you feel it but like
that's pretty thin for a dive watch I
mean who knew who knew you could go with
a cheapo like Teddy and get some great
pieces you're not here with that okay so
let's do some town we'll do some
tallying of money left so you've spent
total let's see
two thousand
this is 2500 so you're looking at 4 500
there
so that's 69
6900 call it six thousand nine hundred
three pieces
sixty nine hundred dollars and I still
have money to spend this is getting
really interesting
let's keep going so here's the situation
Teddy has four thousand dollars left to
spend from his twelve thousand five
hundred and I have fifty six hundred
left to spend on mine against the twelve
thousand five hundred Teddy can't
control his spending [ __ ] and he's
running out of money I have three pieces
he's got three pieces we are definitely
getting one more watch out of this each
let me try to get two wow okay so let's
go you're up now right all right back at
tiso I want to save some money very
famous Swiss brand the last two years
there's been no watch under a thousand
dollars that has caused as much of just
fanaticism as this watch right here tiso
PRX really yes why
it was able to forecast the trend of the
integrated Sports look and then what
ended up happening with we saw with all
the hierology brands everybody's getting
their you know hat in the ring
they were able to do it with a really
well done integrated style bracelet case
and coming in a price starting with the
quartz one just south of it that case
that band that's a legacy look for this
brand it is this is from a sea star
model from 1970s right it was in in
Switzerland and I saw them pull this out
of a tray from the 1970s and it's
basically a one-to-one if you look at
their 35 millimeter so everything old is
New Again is the lesson on this caught
the wave yet a second time decades later
exploded on the scene what's the price
point for the automatic which I'm gonna
go for 650 incredible I mean you've got
a classic look
for under a thousand six hundred dollars
that's insane that's Swiss made yeah 80
hour power Reserve Swiss Movement
automatic it's got this nice it's kind
of a tap history kind of dinosaur that
must be immensely popular at 600 bucks
like we work with TSO we sell them on
our site they just people can't get
enough yeah they can't get enough well
let's get it out let's get this piece
put it to the collection that's really
remarkable check out that bracelet like
also just you know like running I mean
that's
where Brands usually skimp out when you
come to this price range is the bracelet
automatic piece I mean that is a really
stunning dial as well they don't have it
here but they also just recently
unveiled a Chrono version of that yeah
under two thousand dollars but I must
say as it's just a clean classic look an
everyday fantastic go-to watch and I
didn't select it so good for you teddy
but I may steal it from you later we'll
have to see 600 bucks that's all it cost
me amazing absolutely amazing okay
that's good my turn I'm looking for now
brands that I've never touched before
never looked at norcane I've never
looked at nordane why don't you give us
the quick so they're a new upstart brand
the last five years but they've been
adopted pretty quickly for a lot of more
traditional retailers because of what
they've been doing from a manufacturing
perspective so they actually have access
to kinesi movements kinesi is who makes
Tudor movements right so they're
utilizing some of their movements in
their watches so that's why let's talk
about this piece here with the Green Dot
what's the story on that so this is
their GMT and this is actually using one
of their kinesi movements bronze case so
I think your price there I think you're
looking at the fours for that
this caught my eye it's very stunning
it's going to eat a good amount of your
budget it doesn't matter it's style you
know and I'm really putting together a
selection that's going to kick your rear
end 4150 well within my price point and
uh let's see here too let me get this
unscrew if I can now they have it taped
down but this is a true GMT movement as
well so you have isolated function of
your local hour hand into the collection
it goes I mean it's stunning and it's
going to look great with a red band on
it very interesting I've got such
diversity in my dials on this contest
really amazing what a selection
and so what does that get leave me left
I had 56 and I just spent what 4 000
yeah 150. so 1500 bucks give or take
yeah 1500 bucks so I I could probably
pull another watch out of this
you don't know what are you gonna do can
I get one final check of my price I have
3 300 bucks terrible at math Teddy
terrible yeah okay so I can't remember
I'm just yeah
well you're you're limited now there's
not much you can do you're you're down
at you know under a thousand bucks right
how much 3300 my mistake you have plenty
of room yeah I'm really close to this
bomb in Mercier let me just check what
the price is on this moment Mercier
because I think this could be my last
pick this white dial Obama Mercy on the
bracelet I'm right on the edge yeah and
right I'm right on the edge so three
thousand bucks
I'm gonna do it one two three four five
pieces diversity of dial I have my dress
watch I have two everyday watches one's
with a bronze case I then also have my
PRX which is kind of my you know beater
I can do it all with it chronograph and
then I have my more out there but also
diving capable
so I have room for one more piece
um at I think I have 1300 bucks left
what do I have left
do we know
let's have a quick look the first time
we did this the person I was helping us
screwed up and then I went over and then
Kevin penalized me for it so we have to
do the math very important see I keep
them honest to the rules I mean that's
the whole thing I'm compliant
14.50
1450 left that will allow me to get one
more piece I think but very limited in
where I can go you could pretty much
only go to Hamilton yeah
too
yeah I haven't done this
um what do you think is that the right
here the one in the front so that's
their patrimony it's a great watch and
that's well within your price range I'm
gonna take that because I don't have a
dial like that I'm really going dial so
that's probably going to get me right to
a point where there's nothing left I
have a little bit of cash you might have
a little small sliver I I need a small
sliver I'll probably go out for dinner
in New York with it looks like I have
plans you say you rip these guys we do
we do they do surprisingly well because
I think once you get this in your hand
you'll there's sports watches I think
even more so but this is a really killer
piece yeah it's a dress watch you know
it has more of a sector kind of dial you
have the long Gene sector but I think
this is different different enough you
have the dates beautiful just check that
out very very stylish straight and the
price again you're just under a thousand
dollars I believe for that you're right
on a thousand dollars a thousand dollars
so I am going to just take a knee I'm
gonna run out the clock I am done yeah I
think I'm done too because what can I
get for 450 well there's one thing what
is it
you're kidding you can get this t-so PRX
right on there on the strap
well why wouldn't I take that let's open
the Kitchen come on that is amazing just
to actually have one extra watch to you
I'm just being nice yeah maybe you'll be
nice to me well maybe Anything Can
Happen look at that 325 bucks
look at that
and that's the quartz so it is different
that's okay but you know who said you
can't get a great watch at an affordable
price that certainly is
PRX
at a really incredible price point that
is just amazing I'm stunned well you
know Teddy I will say I've learned
something here today but again it's cost
you because I've kicked your butt one
more time no no no no 300 of the rules
here we have to get them all lined up
325 dollars
I told you about that yeah that's
amazing okay let's put it over here have
some respect when we do this now all
right she's stealing let's look at this
all right so let's pull we're going to
pull them all together
fantastic
so we're going to do is we're going to
pull them all together yeah and then
we'll do our final lineup and then you
can make your final decision what you
want to do exactly do it all right Kevin
so we have all the watches in front of
us let's just go through each one so I
have a bomb and mercy just before you
start today I want to make a statement
about this experience because remember
we started with twelve thousand five
hundred dollars I was thinking before we
did our shopping spree maybe three
pieces but that's not what happened
there are so many remarkable timepieces
in this store that you can actually
build a full collection I consider
collections started when you get three
pieces of any collection you start when
you're watch owner when you get to three
you're a collector and you could start
with 1200 500 to become a major
collector because I'm at five pieces
here and then I'm extraordinarily amazed
that I got to six and the 12 500.
and Teddy you're at one two three four
five so I have one more watch in even a
better collection than Teddy has before
he even starts talking about it again
this contest I I know already who won
but that's okay Teddy's learning he's
the grasshopper he's learning from the
master that's the way I look at it
to go through the watches we have the
Obama Mercier Clifton balmatic this has
a five-day power Reserve probably one of
the most remarkable movements you're
gonna find for the money at my tiso PRX
for 650 for that money hard to beat then
I have my aorus big Crown pointer date
in bronze then I move over to my
Hamilton intramatic chronograph that's a
hell of a piece by the way uh-oh I don't
know I don't like how he's talking right
now and then I have my ultracron from
longine which is Marvel in terms of its
movement and what it's bringing forward
because because you're in my my advisor
on these low end entry-level watches
absolutely happy to do it keep going
norcane GMT this one surprised me in
bronze with the kinesi movement on the
inside then you have your Legend diver
here for Mid twos at 36 millimeters
which was an interesting choice this was
the surprise you had a just over 300 PRX
so you're going for the quartz version
but to add an extra watch who wouldn't
do that then you have your big Crown
accavongo Edition from Orris Rado
Captain Cook gray ceramic then your Mido
yeah we had no money left over we spent
pretty much all of our money yeah but we
we got some amazing pieces for twelve
thousand five hundred dollars which I
think of all the things we've done
together Teddy this is going to be a
mind blower because people do not make
the Assumption they can get even one
watch for twelve thousand five hundred
dollars you come to Turner Booker you
come downstairs here you Cruise all of
these displays and you will immerse
yourself in Legend watches incredible
pieces again touting this store as being
probably one of the best places to shop
for watches on Earth I've I've been all
over the world I've never seen anything
like this they spent a fortune building
it but it's worth it
all right Teddy what are you going to do
I'm going to amaze you because I've
looked through both collections your
collection my collection
my collection
Glenn put it this way
this collection
if it was a kitchen and it had a sink
and it had a drain it would flush onto
this collection
this is the elevated collection here
this is absolutely so I'm not going to
do anything I'm not going to do anything
because I've I've clearly
I've I've kicked your ass here today and
I just know that I'm going to let you
vote obviously but there's no I don't
need to change anything my selections
are Beyond perfect they are just the
most incredible mix of dials sport new
looks amazing Brands why would I want to
touch it I was going to go after your
Hamilton but now that I see too much
green you'd have too much green you have
two green gals already you know Green
does work in a Christmasy like way with
red because all of these are gonna end
up with red bands on them but you know I
if I went to green and you're saying I
have too much green I have the same
problem if I take over your Hamilton
which is the only one you've selected I
really really am interested in so the
rest though I mean I did get a green
Vibe today you're right but I'm very
happy with it what fantastic watches and
what a great session with Teddy we will
see you next time and leave comments
down below tell us who won in the
comments did I finally win I don't know
what's going on something's in the water
I don't know what's going on in the
world I think Kevin's winning these
things can you have more fun than this
if you love watches it doesn't get any
better we'll see you next time